In the state parliament of Brandenburg,
an overwhelming majority voted against the
planned increase in broadcasting fees.
The parliamentary groups of the AfD,
CDU, SPD,
left-wing and free voters have united in expressing their
rejection of the proposed increase.
This makes Brandenburg the 1.
federal state that opposes the planned new broadcasting fee.
In the Brandenburg state parliament,
a large majority was against increasing broadcasting fees.
The parliamentary groups of the AfD,
CDU, SPD,
left-wing and free voters have strongly opposed the proposed increase.
This makes Brandenburg the 1.
Federal state that refuses the planned new broadcasting fee.
The only exception is The Green Party,
which as the sole parliamentary group supports
an increase in the broadcasting fee.
The Green Fraktionsvorsitzende Petra bücke defends its position by arguing
that the contribution increase would be only 6 comma 96 euros per year.
This contrasts with the rest of the parties,
which are opposed to an increase in the broadcasting fee
mainly due to a lack of acceptance among the Brandenburgers.